I love paradox and I find paradox as a
source of great richness of insight and
creativity and one of the most beautiful
paradoxes is framed by two very
insightful people one is Tom Friedman
who wrote a book very compelling book
called the world is flat and he made a
very compelling case that with digital
technology infrastructures location no
longer matters
wherever you are you just plug into the
wall connect to the digital
infrastructure and you have everything
you need
very compelling persuasive there's
another guy a man by the name of Richard
Florida who counters that the world is
actually more and more spiky and what he
means by that is that over time there is
an accelerating movement of people into
cities we're becoming more urbanized at
a more rapid rate than ever before
now the paradox is but wait a minute if
the world is flat why are people moving
more and more rapidly into cities you
know and I think that at the end of the
day there's there's elements of truth in
both of these but I what is driving and
from our perspective this movement into
cities there are many many factors at
work but one of them is I think a lot of
us have an intuitive sense that we're
going to learn faster in a city
surrounded by other people that have
similar a complementary talents to us
but we're gonna learn much faster than
in that kind of environment than we
would out in some rural area even if we
can plug in to the network and connect
virtually with anybody we want that
notion in particular of these unexpected
encounters that you have in cities you
know walking down the street sitting in
a coffee shop at the soccer game with
your kids talking to somebody that you
never knew before but when you strike up
a conversation comes up
the really interesting insight helps you
to get through a problem you've been
wrestling with those kinds of
opportunities occur much more richly and
frequently in cities than they do in
rural areas so I think at least
intuitively we have a sense that with
all that digital technology
infrastructure and all the ability to
connect we're gonna be much better off
learn faster in cities than we could on
our own and we have again an intuitive
sense that learning faster is becoming
more and more important but no matter
how much skill we have how much talent
we have at this point in time if we
don't continue to develop that talent
and skill we're gonna become vulnerable
and so that's a powerful motivation to
come into cities and to stay in two
cities